[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler antoine et
oman responsable à la communication
numérique de jean-luc mélenchon et
l'aurait france insoumise eugène d'arona
membre du comité exécutif
d'objectifs france bonsoir à vous
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous ce soir
sur arte france alors d'abord peut-être
qu'on à s'intéresser à alice et j
justement qui regroupe des des
journalistes d'investigation dans une
centaine de pays et territoires à une
centaine de médias aussi en france on y
compte le monde la société de production
première ligne qui produit l'émission
cash investigations sur france 2 la
cellule investigation de radio france il
s'agit d'un réseau créé en 1997
indépendant depuis 2010 est il est basé
à washington
on lui doit beaucoup d'affaires 1 les
off shore l'x les lucs slicks l'eswi
slicks les paradise papers quel crédit
lui apporter s'agit-il d'une entité
réellement indépendante
eugène tarona
ont tout à fait je pense qu en propos
liminaire il faut saluer cette enquête
comme vous l'avez rappelé et un
consortium sont plusieurs centaines de
journalistes un travail de longue
haleine pendant des années 29000
sociétés offshore qui ont été étudiées
une véritable coopération
internationale et je pense qu'à ce titre
on ne peut que saluer l'avancé bas de la
transparence pour faire état est
rapportée de la manière la plus neutre
possible après on verra rentrer un peu
plus dans le 2e set de cette histoire
mais je pense que oui on peut on peut
saluer le travail vous êtes d'accord
antoine né au mans il faut saluer le
travail de cet organisme dont
l'indépendance quand même peut poser
aussi d'aider des questions déjà disons
que effectivement c'est intéressant le
travail de journaliste qui est fait
autour de ça qui permet de dévoiler un
certain nombre de noms le problème qu'il
ya c'est que on aimerait bien avoir la
liste complète puisqu'on se fait faire
les poches par des délinquants en col
blanc on aimerait bien pouvoir tous les
punir et récupérer
l'argent qui est finalement le nôtre il
ya un petit problème quand même dans
tout ça c'est que étant donné que 90%
des médias sont détenus par des
milliardaires et que l'on voit que dans
la liste principalement ses des
milliardaires
peut-être que si le patron des médias
est concerné par ce genre de pratiques
il va y avoir dix ans des petites
réticence à publier le nom de cesser de
ses propriétaires de médias si jamais il
était d' aventure impliqué donc ce qu'il
faudrait pour que la confiance soit
pleine et totale c'est que la liste
intégrale de ceux qui ont fraudé et
riche et soit publié j'ai d'arona là
dessus
je pense que là ensuite seule une
coopération internationale peut faire
vraiment véritablement avancer ces
sujets évidemment c'est un pas en avant
parce que ça permet de remettre ce sujet
sur le devant de la scène et c'est bien
qu'on en parle on le fait on le fait ce
soir ici ensuite il ya de nombreuses
initiatives qui sont prises déjà au
niveau de l' ocde notamment celle qui
est un français pascal saint-amans qui
travaillent sur ces question des paradis
fiscaux ça prend du temps évidemment ça
prend du temps ça laisse cette affaire
va pas être traité du jour au lendemain
et je pense qu'il faut il faut passer la
connivence médias et les milliardaires
je ne peux pas m'exprimer là dessus dans
la mesure où comme l'a dit l'autre
intervenant nous n'avons aujourd'hui pas
les éléments sur les personnes
concernées entre à toutes les personnes
toutes les personnes qu'on est pour moi
ce qui compte c'est que cette cause de
la transparence fiscale avancé je crois
assez efficace le fait qu' on est déjà
quand même certains noms qu'ils soient
publiés parce qu'aujourd'hui la
notoriété c'est ce qui compte aussi pour
les entreprises pour les hommes
influents et je pense que si ça peut
avoir un effet notamment démocratique et
que les citoyens peuvent s'emparer
ensuite de ses sujets et faire pression
justement ça ne pourra que aller dans le
bon sens parce qu'il ya plus de 300
hommes et femmes détenteur de l'autorité
publique qui sont épinglés pas seulement
et des personnalités de tous bords même
le mannequin claudia schiffer en tout
cas ces révélations elle pose la
problématique de l'évasion fiscale
massive qui résiste visiblement aux
nouvelles réglementations fiscales
internationales
comment l'expliquer
renault
trucks d'abord dans ce sujet de
l'évasion fiscale ou de la fraude
fiscale c'est un peu le problème alors
j'ai salué les avancées vous parliez
tout à l'heure du chiffre de 11 300
milliards d'euros ça donne évidemment le
tournis derrière la question c'est
qu'est ce qu'elle est l'arrêté derrière
ces chiffres est ce qu'on parle de
l'évasion fiscale est ce qu'on parle de
la fraude fiscale rappelle que dans un
côté c'est moralement répréhensible de
l'autre côté c'est vrai en cible par la
loi et je crois qu'aujourd'hui le
problème c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait de
ces informations je crois qu'à une
certaine confusion et et je terminerai
par par la chose suivante qui est de
dire que oui il ya des paradis fiscaux
aujourd'hui dans le monde personne ne
peut les lier je pense mais s'il ya des
paradis fiscaux ça veut dire aussi qu'il
y a des enfers fiscaux et je pense que
c'est moi le sujet qui m'intéresse c'est
comment est ce qu'on fait en sorte qu'il
n'est plus d'enfer fils cisco et je
pense évidemment à la france avec le
poids des taxes et réglementations alors
en tout genre notre objectif doit être
et c'est ce qu'on porte avec rafik smati
de faire de la france un véritable
paradis fiscal au sens premier du terme
je pense que l'on doit tous lutter on
est on doit être pour cet objectif
antoine méo m'en voulais réagir je pêche
ouais non je suis pas d'accord ou pas
d'accord du tout avec ça l'impôt est
quelque chose qui a été créé pour
financer des services publics c'est la
mise en commun d'un certain nombre de
ressources pour avoir mieux
collectivement et il ya une manière très
simple de lutter contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale en réalité c'est de
mettre en place ce qu'on appelle l'
impôt universel des états unis le fonds
l'impôt universelle c'est quoi ces vous
habitez dans un autre pays exemple vous
décidé d'habiter au luxembourg eh bien
vous payez vos impôts au luxembourg mais
vous payez la différence au fisc
français de ce que vous devriez en
france si vous étiez restés amis si vous
étiez rester habiter en france voilà une
manière simple et efficace de lutter
contre l'évasion fiscale et de financer
correctement l'état parce que il faut
savoir que la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale chaque année ça représente entre
80 et 100 milliards d'euros c'est-à-dire
un quart du budget de l'état là les
chiffres qui sont données 11/11 vie
enfin 11300 milliards
de dollars ça représente presque cinq
fois le pib de la france donc on voit
que c'est des sommes qui sont
considérables et qu'il ya en réalité des
gens qui sont des traîtres à leur patrie
des gens qui ne n'accepte pas de
participer à l'impôt qui n'acceptent pas
de financer les services publics qui
n'acceptent pas parce qu'ils ont
beaucoup de venir en aide à tous les
autres parce que si les gens gagnent
beaucoup d'argent ils ne le font pas
tout seul dans un monde indépendant des
autres ils le font parce qu'il ya des
gens qui travaillent dans leur
entreprise parce qu'il ya des gens qui
créent la richesse par leur travail et
ces gens là sont des voleurs c'est des
délinquants en col blanc on n'en parle
pas très souvent sur les plateaux télé
qui sont plus intéressés à la petite
délinquance de quartier mais cette
petite délinquance de quartier elle est
aussi liée à des gens qui sont capables
ensuite de blanchir l'argent de
l'utiliser pour faire du trafic d'armes
et finalement toute cette délinquance
c'est un ensemble de choses si on veut
des minquiers pardon si on veut lutter
aussi contre la petite délinquance il
faut être capable de lutter contre la
grosse délinquance contre ceux qui
accumulent des milliards d'euros et qui
ceux qui fuient le fils d un dernier
point peut-être sur ça vous dit qu'il ya
des politiques qui sont dedans c'est un
gros problème parce qu'ensuite comment
avoir confiance dans le fait que ces
gens là sont capables de lutter contre
la fraude et l'évasion fiscale on a
supprimé des postes de contrôleurs
fiscaux or ce sont des postes qui
rapporte de l'argent à un contrôleur du
fisc c'est quelqu'un qui fait gagner de
l'argent c'est un fonctionnaire qui
rapporte de l'argent à l'état et on voit
que les gens qui ont décidé de supprimer
des postes de contrôleurs fiscaux sont
coupable aussi d'avoir aidé cette fraude
et évasion fiscale je peux vous dire que
si jean luc mélenchon arrive au pouvoir
en 2022 c'est quelque chose qui va
changer radicalement nous nous allons
créer des postes et beaucoup dans ce
domaine en juillet dernier sous l'égide
de l'osce et des eaux 130 pays ont quand
même adopter une réforme sur la
fiscalité internationale avec la
création d'un impôt justement sur les
sociétés minimale cela faisait suite à
différentes affaires comme les lucs
slicks ou les panama papers encore les
paradise papers visiblement ce genre de
mesure ce n'est pas suffisant l'évasion
fiscale se montre résilient comment
est-ce qu'on peut lutter efficacement
contre les paradis fiscaux les sociétés
offshore qui s'affranchissent
particulièrement à des règles
eugène verdun
je pense que encore une fois seule la
coopération internationale peut
permettre de lutter contre les paradis
fiscaux vous savez les dernières bruno
le maire est arrivé sur ses grands
chevaux et il a déclaré la guerre aux
gaffard c'est un peu dans le même
registre les gaffes à ne payent pas
d'impôts et il faut donc les faire
contribuer donc on a inventé en france
on a cette passion pour la pauvre pour
la taxe la taxe gaffes et la taxe gaffe
à l'année dernière est ce que vous savez
combien elle a ramené d'argent dans les
caisses du contrôle de l'état français
elle a ramené 375 millions d'euros et
donc ayant et en plus les etats-unis en
ont brandi des menaces de rétention des
barrières douanières et donc on est en
train de faire sauter cette taxe pour au
final avancer sur une base coopérative
au niveau de l' ocde donc je pense que
c'est la seule solution certes les coups
de menton pour pour faire croire qu'on
va pouvoir demain faire entrer 80 100
milliards d'euros dans les caisses de
l'état premièrement je pense que c'est
un peu faire insulte aux agents de de
bercy qui travaillent d'arrache-pied je
pense que si avec 80 milliards d'euros
qui a été à nos portes je pense qu'on
pourrait les trouver évidemment il faut
lutter contre la fraude fiscale mais il
faudrait en fait lutter contre contre
toutes les fraudes mais ensuite il faut
aussi se poser la question de ce qu'est
ce qu'on fait de cet argent encerclent
si demain on trouvait comme le propose
monsieur 80 milliards d'euros je suis
convaincu qu'avec la gestion aujourd'hui
de l'état français on serait incapable
de mettre cet argent intelligemment dans
les hôpitaux dans les écoles dans les
infrastructures dans la transition
écologique et donc il faut voir les
choses du début de la chaîne jusqu'à la
fin allait chercher d'argent bien sûr
s'il y en a mais surprise poser la
question de l'utilisation de cet argent
pour faire
face il est parfois démagogiques vrai
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de cet argent
justement on va regarder cette réaction
via twitter à d'eric coquerel
le pandora peppers confirme les normes
évasion fiscale onze mille 300 milliards
soit quasiment le pib de l'union
européenne
dix fois celui de la france pas d'argent
magique en tout cas un argent volé oui
il manque à l'investissement écologique
à combattre la pauvreté aux services
publics aux salaires antoine hey oh non
ça serait bien peut-être de récupérer
cet argent pour financer nos économies
en europe en france c'est c'est c'est
clair cet argent on en a besoin et après
au premier titre pour financer la
transition écologique et pour financer
finalement même l'adaptation au
changement climatique vous avez
peut-être vu que à marseille aujourd'hui
il ya des pluies diluviennes qui sont
tombées
dans la nuit donc si on veut désormais
c'est des choses qui vont arriver donc
il faut adapter nos infrastructures tout
ça ça va avoir un coût et si on veut
pouvoir les financer il faut récupérer
cet argent là mais de même le service
public un service public de qualité dans
les hôpitaux les écoles et tous les
domaines dans lesquels les services
publics peuvent être utilisés maintenant
quand même il ya un problème c'est que
on ne traite pas ces gens là de la même
manière que les autres dd de la petite
délinquance vous entendre vous en
entendez parler tous les jours à la télé
ces gens là en volant l'argent qu'ils
volent empêche de financer correctement
le service public et à 2000 personnes
qui meurent dans la rue chaque année ces
gens là ont un devoir de partage c'est
un devoir de partage et ils ne le font
pas et il n'y a pas des gens qui les
pourchassent monsieur je voudrais vous
dire aussi une chose vous avez dit je ne
veux pas faire insulte aux agents de
bercy mais moi je ne leur fais pas
insultes au contraire je dis qu'il en a
pas assez jeudi qu'il en faut plus parce
que on aurait grand besoin d'eux pour
aller chercher cet argent pour le
récupérer et leur donner des pouvoirs
d'enquêté élargis pour qu'ils puissent
voilà faire des enquêtes et récupérer
vraiment cet argent ensuite j'ai parlé
d'une autre mesure et je pense que c'est
vraiment la mesure centrale l'impôt
universel mettre en place cet impôt
universel je ne comprends pas pourquoi
on ne le met pas en place puisque les
états unis l'ont fait les etats-unis eux
ont mis en place cette mesure qui permet
d'aller récupérer l'argent là où il est
d'éviter l'évasion fiscale pourquoi la
france ne le fait-elle pas je veux dire
ça fait des années maintenant que cette
proposition est sur la table si elle
n'est pas mise en place c'est bien que
des gens refusent de la mettre en place
ne veulent pas le faire alors même
qu'elle permettrait de récupérer de
l'argent donc encore une fois c'est une
question de volonté politique c'est une
question de choix politique et quand on
voit le nombre de politiques qui sont à
l'intérieur de cette liste faut compter
sur des gens qui sont capables de nommer
ceux qui sont des voleurs et des
fraudeurs du fisc il faut compter sur
des gens qui sont capables de mettre en
place ces mesures et pas sur des gens
qui peut-être en tout cas favorise ces
méthodes d'évasion est en tout cas on
l'a vu des gens qui supprime des postes
chez les contrôleurs du fisc clairement
c'est des gens qui n'ont pas envie de
lutter contre l'évasion et la fraude
fiscales ou gêne d'arona on en a des
gens comme ça qui finalement favorise la
fraude fiscale en france
je comprends la rhétorique qui derrière
derrière ce discours mais en réalité je
pense que ont fait le nécessaire
peut-être pas assez en effet on pourrait
mettre plus de contrôleurs mais d pad on
s'est regardés nécessaire
je pense que si aujourd'hui encore une
fois on avait une baguette magique pour
faire venir cet cet argent frais vous
baguette magique vous partez du principe
partie vous partez du principe monsieur
que la france a un problème d'argent
comme si ils ne sont que l'argent pour
financer la transition énergétique là
mais aujourd'hui monsieur nous avons
plus de mille milliards de prélèvements
obligatoires en france je vais en est
des sommes hallucinantes qui sont
prélevés tout à fait assez de crise
sociale les journalistes à une demande
sociale les gens payent les mac en
trouve à l'hôpital et on ne paye pas
l'école donc oui on arriver grâce à elle
des faubourgs ce qu'on a avec le si on à
la retraite les
si je puis me permettre de finir ma
démonstration penser que la france a un
problème d'argent c'est juste
hallucinant aujourd'hui en 2021 alors
que encore une fois des prélèvements qui
sont massifs donc ok on pourrait aller
chercher plus d'argent mais aussi un peu
comme les discours facile de demain va
stopper l'immigration et ça va nous
rapporter x milliards d'euros demain on
va sortir maintenant les grades l'union
européenne est inséré noir a b x
milliards d'euros je pense qu'il faut
qu'on sort plus logique facile lutter
contre la fraude fiscale évidemment et
être plus ferme mais avec les fraudeurs
fiscaux comme avec tous les fraudeurs
comme avec tout ce qui est riche mais
ensuite réfléchir intelligemment à
l'utilisation qu'on fait de cet argent
et établir des priorités parce que
l'état ne va regarder tout financer un
autre on va regarder notre réaction
parce qu'évidemment cet enjeu autour de
la fraude fiscale mais mais pas
seulement il ya aussi l'argent sale qui
est en jeu et on regarde cette réaction
via twitter de fabien roussel qui est
candidat du parti communiste à la
présidentielle
l'évasion fiscale ces 8000 milliards
d'euros d'actifs financiers tenus dans
des comptes offshore mélanger à l'argent
de la drogue de la traite d'êtres
humains et du trafic d'armes il faut
désintoxiquer nos économies antoine
aller au mans il faut des désintoxiquer
nos économies on voit la kia un enjeu
aussi important des milliers de
milliards de dollars de l'argent sale
peut être aussi un système mondialisé de
finances détourné c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure cet argent qui de
québec est blanchi cet argent de la
fraude dans une certaine mesure dans une
dans une certaine part de cet argent là
il est aussi lié au trafic de drogue il
est aussi liée au trafic d'armes et il
est lié au trafic dont on entend
toujours parler à la télé moi je suis
très choquée d'une chose c'est que ces
gens là sont des voleurs mais à un
niveau qui est mille fois plus important
que le voleur de deux sacs à main dans
la rue ça n'excuse pas le voleur de sac
à main mais on a l'impression qu'on
excuse ce qu'ils sont en train de nous
faire les poches depuis des années c'est
l'argent de tous les français qu'ils
veulent ces gens là sont les voleurs du
peuple tout entier pas de une personne
dans la rue c'est pas des gens qui sont
en train de mourir de faim et qui vont
voler une pomme parce qu'ils essaient de
se nourrir c'est des voleurs des riches
voleurs c'est des voleurs en costume et
au bout d'un moment il faut être capable
de les nommer il faut être capable de
les pourchasser il faut être capable de
les mettre en prison parce que ce sont
des voyous des voyous et il y en a
ras-le-bol de les excuser sans arrêt de
dire que oui les pauvres ils s'en vont
parce que ça serait un enfer fiscal en
france non c'est pas un enfer fiscal en
france on a la sécurité sociale
l'hôpital l'école voilà à quoi ça sert
d'avoir des services publics et de payer
des impôts donc au bout d'un moment les
voleurs en prison basta c'est tout il y
en a ras-le-bol et gêne d'arona
justement là luttant contre la fraude
fiscale peut-être qu'on n'en fait pas
assez est ce que cette problématique
elle doit être au coeur de du débat en
vue de l'échéance électorale à venir
importante la présidentielle et puis
surtout aussi une préoccupation majeure
d'autant plus pour la france qui va
prendre la présidence de l'union
européenne ce sera à partir à 2 janvier
prochain
ouais je pense que c'est un c'est un
vrai sujet comme il yad'autres vrai
sujet pour pour la france la question
c'est en effet dans quel pays est ce
qu'on a envie de vivre aujourd'hui moi
j'ai envie de vivre dans un pays où les
mêmes règles sont appliquées à tous et
encore une fois du coup je rejoins
évidemment les propos de mon
interlocuteur il faut les mêmes règles
pour tous et punir et punir sévèrement
ceux qui trichent mais encore une fois
tous les niveaux austère que et vous
avez raison de dire qu'on ne veut pas
pour autant excuser ce qu'ils font des
petits vols total aujourd'hui on a
aujourd'hui cette culture en france 2
l'excusent de cette culture du
relativisme de ce n'est pas grave une
certaine caution en effet de tout cela
je pense qu'il faut être impitoyable
avec ceux qui trichent ça veut dire
qu'il faut aussi réformer notre justice
puisque derrière la justice aujourd'hui
est en manque criant de moyens donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'eux des gens qui
trichent si on n'est pas capable
derrière et vous faites un vol
aujourd'hui demain le lendemain vous
êtes libérés enfin cette société n'est
pas tenable lorsque pour refaire société
puisque encore une fois je parlais de
dans quelle france nous avons envie de
vivre et de construire pour demain la
société elle ne tiendra que avec la
confiance aujourd'hui une telle défiance
envers nos élites évidemment envers
envers les politiques que six ans donné
elle pas des mesures claires qui
viennent contrecarrer et redire aux
citoyens ok que vous soyez petits moyens
ou grands
si vous respectez la loi il n'y a aucun
souci vous pourrez on pourra continuer à
vivre ensemble par contre le premier qui
va commencer à déborder sera sévèrement
puni je peux vous dire qu'on créera les
conditions d'un nouveau contrat social
pense que la france pourra prendre toute
sa part chez nous au niveau de l'union
européenne évidemment puisque nous
allons prendre la présidence merci à
vous eugène d'arona membre du comité
exécutif d'objectifs france et merci à
vous en toi de l'est au mans responsable
à la communication numérique de jean-luc
mélenchon et de la france insoumise